monsieur il y a deux ans andré et
dolorès décide d'avoir un enfant pour l
direction la belgique puisqu'elles ont
opté pour l'insémination artificielle
aujourd'hui le petit arthur à 15 mois on
insiste bien sur le fait qu'il a demain
à faire joujou y la maman d'eau et maman
on insiste bien sur ce fait la queue
nous appellent toutes les deux mamans et
quand y en a une qui est pas là il
appelle l'autre sans problème
entretien psychologique pour
l'insémination enquête de gendarmerie
pour que de leur s obtiennent l'autorité
parentale multiples rendez-vous avec le
curé pour qu'arthur puisse être baptisé
le couple a enchaîné les démarches pour
construire une famille
on a trouvé ça un peu injustifiée de
nous demander vont traquer les
entretiens qu'elle traiterait tu sais
quelles ont été nos relations en visuel
nos relations amoureuses sans enjeu dire
que ça n'a rien à voir quoi
on en est là aujourd'hui nous ça fait
dix ans qu'on est ensemble on fait pas
on ne fait pas semblant et on est comme
sonné et voilà c'est comme ça quand on a
rencontré le prêtre
sa crainte c'était qu'on élève arthur
dans l'homosexualité qu'il devienne un
guerrier comme lourd donc on a dû lui
prouver par a plus b que nous on veut
être grand mère au bout du compte ça il
faut se justifier faut se déshabiller
pour les trains aujourd'hui le couple
aimerait bien sûr se marier pour
qu'enfin dolores puisse avoir une place
au niveau juridique dans la vie d'arthur
et pour qu'elles puissent également lui
donner son nom si le mariage homosexuel
n'est pas accordé je pourrais le rapport
présenté qu'à saint malo xkcd chasseurs
18 ans pour aller la voir elle avait
toute sa vie aucun intérêt
s'il ya de ça j'attends voici 18 ans
j'adapterai l'office hadopi c'est pas
comme un mariage homosexuel autorisé ou
non le couple souhaite d'ores et déjà à
agrandir la famille et bientôt un
nouveau voyage en belgique sera
organisée